so I'm still getting through my stories
about the irresponsible virus
disinformation that's happening each
weekend and a lot of it is happening on
Fox News and there's so much of it it's
taking me through Tuesday to actually
get caught up on it so I want to go
through a little bit of judge Jeanine
Pirro show from this weekend on Fox News
here's judge Jeanine asking I know
people are dying I know people are sick
but what about the rest of us we just
have to stay home another example of
embracing the let them die strategy that
we talked about earlier today been
sheltered in their homes who've been
patiently watching this unfold have seen
the data and the facts changed from day
to day
first there were 2.2 million who were
supposed to die in the United States and
then it was a million then it was
500,000 then 250,000 and supposedly
mitigation was already taken into
account those numbers okay we have to
stop first of all a judge using the word
suppose ugly come on okay and she's
wrong 2.2 million was the possible death
toll if we did nothing and this is a
game that they're playing now to say hey
we could have lost 2.2 million and now
we might only lose 60,000 so therefore
Trump is a hero 2.2 million was if
literally nothing was done which no
president could actually get away with
it seemed like Trump was going to do
nothing at first but obviously he could
not actually get away with doing nothing
it's a ridiculous bar to be saying we
could have lost 2.2 million anything
shorter anything short of that is a
victory by Donald Trump let's continue
though and we understand there are still
many sick and dying and density and hot
spots are to be treated differently but
what about the rest of us we want to go
back to work feed our families and as
the governors sit there and pontificate
we are the ones experiencing the reality
that for every percentage drop in
employment there are five to ten
thousand deaths occurring depression
suicide domestic violence child abuse
resurgence of alcoholism drug addiction
loss of hope
battered women locked at home with their
abusers abused children not being
identified or protected because they
cannot go to school I'll wear my mask my
gloves and I'll keep my distance and
I'll do the testing whether to determine
if I have kovin or whether I have the
antibody but don't you even think about
tracing or tracking or giving me a card
it ain't happening if you're wondering
if she's drunk again I don't know the
answer
judge Jeanine appeared visibly impaired
on her show a few weeks ago it's less
clear this time but she's certainly not
making any more sense regardless people
are sick and dying but what about us the
answer is you get to live hopefully you
hopefully don't get sick or die that's
what we are going for here and judge
Jeanine continues with her rant and she
does seem more unhinged than normal
whether it's an alcohol-related or not I
do I don't know but very very unhinged
your models are out of control the
economy is out of control China is the
one that's out of control we're not
going to let you destroy this country or
our way of life we've worked too hard
and we fought too long to lose it to a
woman that's what I said a woman virus
that China knew about openly lied about
said it couldn't be transmitted from
human to human and intentionally
protected Chinese citizens from the
virus but allowed that virus to be
released putting the rest of the world
at risk you want to control people you
politicians want to flex your muscles
we'll start working on how you're going
to punish ostracize alienate and
financially sanction and make China
accountable for what they did to us and
the rest of the world of course the
economy recovers dead people don't
recover judge Jeanine who was actually a
judge once which is crazy is ranting in
a way that's not that different from the
guy urinating in the subway station
while ranting about the second coming of
Christ or whatever there's a
then we get to the cherry on top judge
Jeanine actually brings on a protester
this is a protester from Michigan and
praises the protester I guess for
putting people at risk of infection take
a look
Denny dent Dingell who is the pitcher
senator didn't have nice things to say
about you guys and I was rather shocked
here she is a representative of your
state criticizing this this peaceful
protest and it was pre Tempe SFIL saying
it was inexcusable what water Michigan's
reaction to her well I can tell you look
at Michigan look the nation what we've
done with operation gridlock and has
ignited a fire that has spread across
this entire nation Arizona Pennsylvania
Texas I mean today New York great
example of gridlock people rising up all
across this nation all right and you
know a lot of people are very proud of
you Michonne and what you've done and
let me just say Debbie Dingell is a
congresswoman and not a senator of
course the issue isn't whether it was a
peaceful protest again they are just
completely changing the parameters of
the discussion the peaceful nature of
the protest isn't an issue the public
health risk of the protest is what's at
issue they called it operation gridlock
they are grid locking streets and
preventing patients who need care from
getting to hospitals and this is how the
echo chamber works we're seeing it
happen in real time
Trump tweets about liber8 Michigan
liber8 Minnesota whatever Trump says
protesters are being responsible even
when they're not and then judge Jeanine
brings on a protester and acts like
they're doing some amazing principled
thing when all they're doing is putting
people at risk of getting the virus and
compromising the long-term economic
stability of the country remember
they're insisting that in the short term
opening will be good economically maybe
it will maybe it won't but what we know
from the 19
flu pandemic is premature opening is bad
economically in the medium-term and here
you see FoxNews sort of pick it up and
carry water openly promoting and
supporting the protests against social
distancing measures on which we are all
relying to keep us safe this is the
situation in which we find ourselves
it's not a bad dream
we can't just wake up from it we're
dealing with this in reality let me tell
you real quick about one of our sponsors
cuts clothing they offer super quality
men's t-shirts and they're giving you
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash cuts that's see UTS because solid
color t-shirts are a really important
staple in pretty much every guy's
wardrobe I think it's really important
not to overlook the value of having
t-shirts you love wearing t-shirts from
cuts clothing have been a game changer
for me and as a company all they deal
with are men's
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS